he's one of my favorite people on planet
earth 17 seasons as a player and yes
it's the 10th anniversary he's in trial
it is Rod Woodson ten years ago ten
years ago I got inducted you guys almost
made me cry when I came back to the set
and you guys had my whole family set up
in my house and I was awesome you know
but it's only here that I get to where
they go Jackie because when I'm at home
my wife says you can wear the go jacket
don't wear the go jacket wear the ring
don't Wittering clean the toilet take
out the trash I don't care what you do
if I had a gold jacket I would I would I
would walk around town with it just like
how how you doing yeah that's it I'm
going on I'm taking the jacket I'm going
to get gas everywhere everywhere
everywhere yeah I think so that's what I
would do but that's the difference
between me and you I guess Ron but that
was a special night for me because
Berman introduced Ralph Wilson whose
name is on the building that were
sitting in right now the wing and that
meant I get to I I did the whole
enchilada and the fact that I was able
to be the host and you were the guy
going in that was amazing it was a very
special thing for me to stand back there
like I've watched you deliver to the
whole large amazingly large group of
people that came to see you it was
really special
yeah we go way back like mosquito that's
rich we do we're close what does that
mean we're close always that what that
mean you're close IIIi don't know where
I got that one for oh I don't know maybe
you picked that there's a lot of
mosquitoes in Indiana so maybe so okay
good to see you what so let's I guess
get into a little bit of the news of the
day you just heard we had a conversation
about Zeek Elliot sitting there in Kabul
you heard with our buddy or our buddy
and your fellow hall-of-famer who's in
that room right across the way Marshall
Faulk ah to say and that's a window into
what Zeke's talking about I mean
Marshall and rocky Arceneaux or like
like what is that ski ski tonight okay
that's who they are and he's saying you
know why do we need a market reset in
the running back
market they want to reset the market
what are your two cents on the what's
going on with Zeke in the Cowboys yeah I
mean you know the new thing in the
National Football League for some reason
is that we can always do running back by
committee everybody's always saying that
you hear it all the time but when you
get game-changing players at a position
you don't need running back by committee
you need somebody to take a breather
away from him I mean Zeke is one of
those guys you know Le'Veon Bell is one
of those guys girl he's one of those
guys Camaro is one of those guys you
don't find those players too often and
when you do find them you can't say it's
gonna be running back by committee
because when you look at the success
that they've had the last couple years
or the sexes they didn't have it was
about Zeke Zeke was running the show it
I know dak was getting a lot of he gets
a lot of love and he did play well for
him but it that often Tran threw him
where today the game is ran through the
quarterback normally and that's what you
know Marshalls saying you know a lot of
quarterbacks which he is absolutely 100%
correct making a lot of money who do not
deserve it and they say it's because of
the market whatever that is that sounds
just like you Brockman you and I love
having the same opinion as Hall of
Famers you know and and I you know what
my approach is that I understand that
certain players who have not won playoff
games or certain players who have only
won a small amount of playoff games are
about to hit it towards the tune of 30
million bucks here that is the market
and it's funny how for quarterbacks you
got to pay him because that's what the
market is but running backs are a
different story and the way I'm looking
at it to hear you you tell me if you
think I'm onto something is the Cowboys
have built their team to have somebody
like Zeke be the center of that universe
so you know at some point the way that
you're building the team and how special
he is on the field you're gonna have to
pay them what the market bears in terms
of breaking the market right so the
reason why they're not is what do you
think that they're thinking like
whatever's gone on off the field causing
them to try and have a hitch in their
giddyup here and they don't say that
publicly because it calls him out with
it right I think there's two fold first
you know he still has two years
do what they I think it's somewhere
between twelve point five to thirteen
million dollars so he's still making six
million a year from his rookie contract
you know if if I'm a GM if I'm running
the organization if I a player comes to
me with two years left on his contract
saying I don't play my contract I'm like
no you didn't you still got two years in
your contract now if you come in and we
can work out a good-faith compensation
package for you
that's different I'm not a fan of
players under contract not coming into
camp and asking for more money I know
it's you know everybody's gonna say it's
a short career you know you got to get
it when you can I get it but there's
still some professionalism has to be
brought into the table from the player's
perspective it can't be all about the
team the team can't be the one doing all
the giving and the player has no nothing
that he gets back so I think giving back
by his coming in saying that hey listen
I'm underpaid you guys know I'm
underpaid but let's work on a why I'm
here why not do that instead of sitting
out I mean levy on Bill you know he
thought he's gonna get more money than
he got he like he left 14 and a half
million dollars on the table you'll
never get that back so whoever advised
him to do it even though he left
Pittsburgh went to the Jets which I
think you're kind of happy no no I am
appreciative of it and I'm I'm as a jet
observer happy happy that that Brian
Khalil signed there I think that was
significant you know today that's very
very significant with a young
quarterback and a running back he's got
this body surfing style of running who
needs to pick and choose where he's
going to have the time to do that right
I like that see now the difference
between levian
and Zeke is that levian wasn't in the
contract they offered him his franchise
package he said he didn't want to sign
anything with a long-term deal right and
given the right package he didn't want
it that's different
Zeke is tolling the contract you know
get the money yes I I held out twice
when I was
dealers I understand that but I wasn't
under contract first time is when you a
rookie browser rookie my rookie year I
held out all the way until October 28th
my rookie season and then the following
didn't show up till like week eight your
rookie season or so yeah I'm gonna play
like ten games whatever Chuck null say
to you when you finally came in hey I
wasn't a starter I played safety more my
rookie year in a corner so they put me
at safety is like that was my natural
position anyway cuz I know you you you
ran track in Berlin right was you I was
in Berlin I was in Nice I was in Paris I
was in Barcelona well we're there when
the Steelers were expecting you when the
Steelers are expecting me to sign so I
was running track at the European
circuit which was awesome but what did
the old man
Rooney say maybe what are you saying he
really didn't say removed okay you know
but I mean the one thing I did is that
you know I came in and but I set an
example to them that if I said I was
gonna do something I was gonna do it but
I wasn't under contract if I was gonna
be under contract I would have came in
howdy came in and said listen I'm
underpaid let's talk about this
proposition package in good faith why
I'm here Rod Woodson here on the Rich
Eisen show to just wrap this up as you
know when we went to break I said no
matter what's going on with Dallas and
Zeke that if healthy if he's a healthy
human being on the planet he will be the
week 1 starter for the Dallas Cowboys
and I would eat the Hat on Mike Dell 2fo
said do you think as we are sitting here
one preseason game into August I should
get a fork knife and or ketchup so I'm
not ready what do you think I would
think not I think you're you're good on
that bet okay I mean you think about it
they don't really have you starting
running back rod Smith is going they
don't know then but that's why you
sitting in combo because exact laps was
absolutely because he's like because
that next step on the depth chart is a
Lulu it is it is but you know I would I
would love to see him come in and deal
with good faith I'm a professionalism I
know he's not gonna do it I know the I
know these kids are different coming in
the league today I wish he would he's
not gonna do it anyway but you know if
they hold a hard stance
yes I'm I find that was
Cowboys I'm holding hard stances that I
am NOT talking to anybody was under
contract who's not gonna be in our camp
Rod Woodson here on the Rich Eisen show
Tomlin got a one-year extension now why
why do so many Steeler fans have Tomlin
fatigue rod well tell me about this here
look Mike is Mike is a he's never had a
losing season
that's ahead good that's a fact that's a
fact I think the one thing they seen the
dysfunction a little bit in a locker
room from the lack of leadership that's
come from in there and until the players
take ownership of who they are in the
locker room
then the team never becomes the
teammates should be but sometimes a head
coach has to be that guy to put the
thumb down on individuals and I think
you know the downfall of the team I
can't say down fall for the downfall
some of their seasons has been some of
those negative things that happen you
know soon was like a bee did the
Instagram you know video and in the
locker room live-streaming yes he should
have been suspended for next week I
would have suspending them next week
like you're not gonna do that and you're
not gonna play I don't care how good you
are the team comes before you're a
little selfish little act that you have
he hasn't done that I think that it like
swearing people out in the area I
haven't talked about anybody about it
right in the Pittsburgh area I would
think that could be some domain calls it
okay now I don't know if a rookie can do
you know the leadership role but they
did draft a Michigan man right there in
the middle of that defense it's exactly
who they are missing his Devon Bush yeah
what do you think of this kid I like him
um you know he's not a real big guy but
you don't need the Ray Lewis is that
Brian Urlacher's in the middle anymore
you don't need them to be that big Mike
back or anymore everybody's played in
space so having a guy like that who can
run move cover the smaller individual
backs coming out of the backfield in the
middle of the field and feeling
comfortable with him being there right
that's the key they moved up ten spots
together they never do that
I mean therefore they never that move up
in the draft people but I think they
seen the value of what they need from
the Mike position because we're you know
Ryan shazier was that guy does
unfortunately he got the had the injury
and since he's been gone they've had
they really haven't had that playmaker
that Levi Lima sideline and so hopefully
he can I don't know he's gonna be the
leader vocally right but if he's a
leader by by actions on the field right
that's what they need on game day
because offensive ly I think they're
gonna be okay well I think we have a
good running game I think Jude is gonna
be okay McDonald's there you still got
Ben it's the defense never having a guy
who can make plays in the big games when
since Troy left they need to find a guy
like that well I've wrought I mean Ben
and then you say they got Ben no more
radio show don't think I think he
shuddered his radio show that's a good
idea that's a good idea that's we'll
check that and and it invited receivers
to Georgia and work out that's a good
idea
another one checked that is do we have a
different Ben Roethlisberger do you
think we'll find out you know I mean
everybody says they are
you know they can show different things
but when you get into the heat of the
moment and games and then after the game
say it's a critical loss what does he do
does he throw his boys under the bus or
does he throw himself under the bus I
mean he's the answer the answer is both
the answer is both
well you it's it's like you know it's
like well that this you know did you you
know was supposed to run a post and he
kind of cut it off a little bit and we
were off on the the same page and I got
to do a better job like that that's
that's the Ben we've heard in the past
it's like a little bit of bus throwing
right and then a but I've got to do
better right that's the one we've that's
the one we've heard I think most the
great players to me always take
ownership 100% of what happened right
wrong right or it doesn't really
especially when it's wrong yes you take
ownership and that's when you guys you
have your back like he didn't them you
know it was that's good I'm gonna run
the right route next time and I think
when you do that you find the leaders
that you need in your locker room rod
what's a few more minutes left with the
with with you
speaking of locker room the one across
those hallways this the greatest what is
it like to be in that room across them
it's it's it's fun you know I mean it's
um we have like the we have a group of
grumpy er guys their little odor it's
like a group of them I'm not gonna name
any names like
Groo probably like never smile they were
always serious and then you have the
other group that's never serious always
joking and then you have the group in
between but you're the in-between I'm
in-between sometimes I'm serious or
something like but you know the one
thing I love about is that you know you
look at and I'm with Joe Greene
mal Bunn who I think is the best corner
to ever play in a National Football
League you know you get to see you know
I mean I didn't see Danny there but you
know John is there you see none of the
Warriors in Murray know you're talking
danny moreno Kenya you know you don't
see any of the 49er guys there I think
they think they're too good to come here
rice in Montana or not in that room
you're saying no they're not in that
room yeah rice Montana young must be
doing something in Cali paying taxes or
something like that I don't know oh you
saw the grump it yourself right yeah
yeah well I'm a little I'm a little
upset because I'm you think about this
there's only a hundred and something
living Hall of Famers right you seem
like every year if you're not working
you should be coming back here just pay
homage to everything that's happened in
your life to get you to where you're at
today so whatever the jobs are in
whatever doors opened up for them it
opened up because they played this sport
so I'm a little disappointed that more
guys don't come come back but the guys
who do come back it's a great time it's
great being in that room it's great hear
some of the stories that it's going to
come up in the next couple minutes sure
and then the young guys who went in last
year I call him young but new but the
young Hall of Famers that came in last
year they get that to speak for the
first time this years okay so that's how
it works like how the young guys like so
Tony ed Reed don't say nothing you got
to be quiet you got to listen to your
baby but then the guys that came in last
year they can finally speak this year
because now they're a Hall of Famer
did you just call Gil Brandt a baby goes
in Reverse rich it's like he's like the
Benjamin Button he's a baby here in Kent
for this one day it's for this one day
for this one day yeah I've never seen a
baby with a king but yeah
today we are you getting some some DB's
in big-time yeah
Edie and and Robinson are going in I
mean there's a ton of pics being at it
right now just I'll just quickly before
I let you go I know you got to go across
the way just give you the floor on on on
these guys and what makes them Hall of
Famers bro well I mean anytime you find
when you look at all hall-of-famer
special for the DB side of it they're
they're balls you know I always I tell
guys all the time when you play DB
there's more you can touch that football
the more you're valuable to your
football team and every single one of
them had a lot of pics ever seen one of
them change games in their time frame
when they played and they were that
shutdown corner so to speak when they
played and when you find those type of
guys they become special and they get
this go jacket it's amazing
go go go across the way enjoy rod thanks
for appreciate up and I love you man
you're the best man you got absolutely
that's Rod Woodson everybody Pro
Football Hall of Famer four more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app